county school district wants to address
its ongoing teacher shortage
a news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the steps they are taking
to find and more importantly keep
educators
we've had an issue and really been
recruiting and retaining our educators
a problem superintendent dr jesus draw
is making a priority
our goal and target by the end of our
strategic plan
is that we minimize and we have a zero
vacancies in our schools
what is our teacher shortage right now
in the district
so as of yesterday
we were 269 classroom teachers
short a new 22-page report highlights
ways to address the challenge
the recommendations come from the
recruitment and retention advisory
commission
a group dr jara formed last year
comprised of various community partners
focusing on
areas of improvement this is a report
that is really going to be action driven
here are the suggestions for recruitment
starting the hiring process
sooner also grow new and quality diverse
teacher pipelines
and maximize existing ones like from
local universities
currently there's a third of all of our
ccsd annual hires come from outside of
nevada
regarding retention enhancing mentorship
and coaching for administrators as well
as teachers at every experience level
also improving the current culture
survey and
expanding the exit survey to all
educators
about 12 percent of year one teachers
leave the school district after their
first year
and 14.9 percent of experienced teachers
resign for reasons other than retirement
addressing the data to find and keep
teachers here
kristen drummond 8 news now the
commission plans to check in on a
regular basis with the district to
monitor the progress of the advised
solutions and we reached out asking you
on twitter
with about four months left in the
academic year do you think students
should
return to the classroom 65 percent
actually said
no 35 percent say yes